[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily a los angeles police
officer attacked in his own precinct
you got my gun you got my gun
how officers captured the suspect and a
foiled plot to kidnap the michigan
governor
why state and federal authorities are
charging 13 men
with terrorism an actual criminal
conspiracy or was it
a bunch of you know rejects sitting
around in a basement just
talking fantasy plus rapper tory lanez
is charged with shooting fellow rapper
megan the stallion
and on appeal court to hear the latest
in bill cosby's case
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
we begin with the shocking body cam
video from a los angeles police officer
investigators say jose guzman walked
into a police station
and attacked an officer guzman is
accused of wrestling with the officer
stealing his weapon and pistol whipping
the officer
the officer is seen bleeding as a
suspect seat
with him and his own gun several shots
were fired but no one was hit
guzman fled the scene and was later
arrested he's facing multiple charges
including attempted murder of a law
enforcement officer
here's some of the body cam video
hey you got my gun
you got my gun
guzman was taken into custody following
a non-categorical use of force
the officers loaded nine millimeter
beretta semi-automatic pistol
was recovered from guzman's vehicle the
lafd paramedics also responded to the
station
and transported the injured officer to a
local hospital where he was medically
treated for non-life-threatening
injuries
and was later released and now
to michigan where authorities have
charged 13 men with plotting to kidnap
the governor
law and crime dailies terry austin has
combed through the criminal complaints
and has more for us terry bryant state
and federal law enforcement teamed up to
unravel this alleged massive plan
that is being called domestic terrorism
according to the indictment the men
plotted to storm the state capitol
building
overthrow the michigan government and
take governor gretchen whitmore hostage
fbi agents say they also overheard the
men
talking about using molotov cocktails to
destroy police vehicles
some of the individuals are believed to
be part of a rogue militia group
michigan attorney jamie white told me
his brother
was one of the arresting officers
the conspirators to kidnap
discussed you know attacking police
stations blowing up bridges doing things
to interfere
you know with the law enforcement
response to the actual kidnapping while
the other group actually um were
targeted because
it became known to law enforcement they
were seeking the addresses
of certain law enforcement officers here
in the state of michigan
in fact but for the immediacy
of needing to thwart this plan i suspect
that law enforcement probably would have
followed these individuals for
as long as they could but obviously
the governor's life and her family is
more important
than anything so they stepped in
more secrecy in the case against the
woman known as the madam to the
millionaire pedophile
jeffrey epstein federal prosecutors are
seeking to keep
evidence hidden against elaine maxwell
they're citing to a connection
to the ongoing sex trafficking case
against jeffrey epstein
as a reason to withhold documents and
photos from the defense team
that apparently identify victims abused
by epstein
prosecutors want a judge to allow them
not to hand over the evidence
until eight weeks before the start of
maxwell's trial
saying the scope of the epstein
investigation is not currently public
criminal defense attorney and law and
crime legal analyst gigi gonzalez
says defendants have a constitutional
right to confront their accusers
so it's important for the prosecutors to
deliver this evidence
however this is not an unusual situation
especially when you have special victims
such as minors
you know involved in this case so the
judge is going to have to
balance out the constitutional right
of the defendant to be able to prepare
adequately for trial
and also the victims right to not have
their
information uh you know dispersed
throughout the public and this is a very
high profile case
where any information that comes out
about this case is going to be received
on an international level
so it's a very important balance but i
do think that
you know the prosecutors in this case
asking the judge to consider allowing
them releasing this information to the
defense
within eight weeks of the trial um i
don't think is reasonable
the defense deserves an ample amount of
time
or a reasonable amount of time to
prepare a defense
for what's going to be a very
long-winded trial
the 17-year-old accused of murdering two
people and injuring a third
after crossing state lines for a protest
in wisconsin
is fighting extradition kyle rinhaus
appeared in court virtually
as his defense argued that their client
is being treated unfairly
and that extradition would be the same
as turning him over to the mob
house is charged with shooting three
people out of protest in kenosha
wisconsin
people there took to the streets after
the police shooting of jacob blake
reyna house was arrested at his home in
illinois
his defense says he is defending him he
was defending himself
during the protest terry
let's come to you first the defense is
making a lot of constitutional
and procedural arguments against
extradition do you see any of these
arguments working
i don't think they're going to work
brian you know the arguments against
extradition
usually include the wrong identity or
the fact that the defendant has never
been charged with the crime
or even insufficient allegations i guess
you could make a constitutional argument
under the 14th amendment
that he is being deprived of life
liberty or property that's sort of a
catch-all that there wasn't you know
due process but i don't think that
argument is going to
be you know prevail and uh even if we
did
we'd never been able to uh get
defendants to the state that we need to
get defendants so i i don't think it's
going to prevail
all right dina doll i want to thank you
first for joining us today and i want to
ask you this question
kyle rittenhouse has become a polarizing
figure in america
he's a patriot to some alleged murderer
to others
could politics be affecting his
potential safety
as he's scheduled to move from a
juvenile detention center to a jail for
adults it's possible like you said he
has
gained notoriety by inserting himself
into what was already a national
story but they know how to protect
people even
in prison and he might end up in a more
safe location within the prison that
happens a lot with celebrities as well
because it is true if you have some sort
of notoriety your safety in a prison
could get affected
makes sense to see if there's any kind
of special consideration because of that
notoriety
still ahead on law and crime daily actor
and comedian bill cosby's appeal
will be heard by the pennsylvania
supreme court
and later on the iowa mother accused of
strangling her
five-year-old daughter with a pair of
pajamas faces a retrial
who'll decide kelsey thomas's fate we'll
discuss after this break
[Music]
an iowa mother accused of strangling her
five-year-old daughter to death
with a pair of pajama pants is getting a
new trial
a jury acquitted kelsey thomas of child
endangerment but was hung on the murder
charge
firefighters found chloe thomas dead in
her bedroom on july 19
2018. thomas told detectives she put
chloe down for a nap around 1
30 pm and then settled down for a nap
herself
when she awoke she says she found her
daughter dead
in the closet and called 9-1-1
prosecutors say the defendant confessed
to the murder
the defense argued the confession was
coursed
and she had jumped out of her bed
and i tried to grab her
[Music]
honestly if
[Music]
um
[Music]
the medical examiner ruled chloe's
manner of death as a homicide
but the defense won a motion to prevent
that testimony from coming in court
however the medical examiner was able to
testify
that chloe's cause of death was
strangulation
there was injury of the carotid arteries
just above where the clavicles are
so it's lower than i would expect with
a typical suspension it's on both sides
of the neck
and it's more common with
with a strangulation a manual
strangulation
type of injury there was
in fact a struggle chloe had been moving
her mom had been moving and the
pants which were essentially the
ligature
would have been in a position to
shift on her neck as the
bodies shifted in their movement
chloe turned which would account for
some of that
injury in the back of her neck as well
as the front
on cross the defense wanted to know
whether the medical examiner
relied on the defendant's alleged
confession to reach those conclusions
i think that the story is
completely consistent with the sequence
of events
that are described with
a an asphyxial death
such as strangulation or suspension
it was more my autopsy findings
the irregular ligature furrow
that was upwardly canted but associated
with
internal injuries including
the petechiae of the larynx the vocalist
muscle hemorrhage
the asphyxial evidence of neuropathology
that was more in keeping with the second
story
than the first story which would have
been
a sling-like apparatus
all right dina you got to explain this
one to me the defense got a hung jury on
the top charge
and an acquittal on the lower charge
this time a judge will decide her fate
what do you make of this strategy to do
a bench trial rather than a jury trial
when they had so much
positive outcomes on the first time
yeah very surprising and especially
surprising that they acquitted of the
lesser charge you think
actually the reverse would have happened
and i wonder if the coronavirus timing
had anything to do with that
this judge must have throughout the
first trial
seemed sympathetic toward the defense in
terms of the ruling that judge made in
order for
the defendant to want to have a bench
trial
that and the fact that jurors are
notoriously
harsh judgers of women who are accused
of killing their children so i think
that combination
must be the reason why they've requested
a bench trial yeah it's got to be
something behind closed doors or not
seeing maybe the judge gave a wink and a
nod and made the defense think they got
a better try with them
now terry many defense attorneys believe
that the advantage in a re-trial
actually goes to the prosecutor do you
think we're going to see the same trial
in front of just a different jury or do
you think either side will change their
game plan
well you know brian i think both sides
should change their game plan
based on what they've seen i actually
think it's pretty even
the defense obviously has a chance to
see what the prosecution is going to
bring
and the prosecution can improve their
arguments get better witnesses or
more evidence and make a better argument
so if anyone has a disadvantage in my
opinion
because the prosecution has the burden
of proof i think
it might be harder to get witnesses to
seem sincere
all right and an offender is not afraid
to speak his mind and question a judge's
motives
stay with us
one defendant in kentucky was not afraid
to voice his opinion
in this crazy courtroom moment court cam
by law and crime productions airs on the
a
e network here's our founder dan abrams
we now take you to the jefferson circuit
court in louisville kentucky
and it's my right to speak blind to
speak on this is bryce rose
a man very familiar with the louisville
courts
he's been behind bars since he was
charged with the murder of one man in
2016
and two teenage brothers a month later
fearing they would tell police of his
involvement in the first crime
since that time rhodes has been locked
up awaiting trial
but moving forward has been challenging
due to rhodes disruptive behavior in
court
and in jail he's even gone so far as to
threaten judge amber wolf from behind a
spit guard in 2016.
you can just bring him up right here
i think you know why you know exactly
why
now listen stop talking i'm going to
keep talking because i don't want to
have to see you back here for this
so you're saying you're going to find
out where i'm at
okay that was a threat against the court
i think that
i'm asking the county attorney's office
to take that into account
and consider what to do with that after
this incident
rhodes was charged with terroristic
threatening in the third degree and
intimidating a participant in the legal
process
four years later march of 2020 he's at
it again don't show favoritism to the
commonwealth you deny every emotion i've
ever found in this courtroom
i'm still gonna it's my right to follow
pro state motion and it's my right to
speak what i need to speak on
after judge charles cunningham denies
his motion to dismiss the murder charges
he questions the judge's motives
probably have some type of sexual
relationship going on
or which i got going on but i'm
definitely going to speak my mind
detective datelli and i have
no sexual relationships sir
sorry you're not all emotions every
emotion i've found you didn't do that
pretty sure i've denied the best
majority of crosstalk emotions that are
very fast are you some type of racist
are you or you got some type of sex
relationship going on which one is it
or are you just wrong and everything
that you've made a motion for
are you going to be the two pluck
slammer no sir i'm not sure you really
are
i think rhode's attorney has
clearly seen this before i'm not but
like i said the higher reports still
deal with it with time
that's exactly right judge cunningham
takes it all in stride
because rhodes remains behind bars and
faces life in prison
if convicted of the crimes as of this
taping
rhodes's cases are still awaiting trial
and when we come back bill cosby's
defense team argues his appeal
to the pennsylvania supreme court
[Music]
bill cosby is scheduled to have his
appeal heard by the pennsylvania supreme
court in december
cosby is serving a three to ten year
prison sentence for sexual assault
the state's high court has agreed to
review two key issues
one of the issues is over the trial
judge's decision to allow
other accusers to testify about their
old claims
the second is whether the jury should
have heard evidence
that cosby had given quaaludes to women
in the past
professor in law and crime expert joseph
scott morgan explains the effects of
quaaludes could have
on the women it puts
the victim in a state almost of
catatonia you
they claim that with this drug there is
kind of a
semi-awareness that things are happening
but can you can you just imagine just
fathom for a moment
you have no control uh over over your
limbs you have no control many times
over your speech you can't protest this
goes to serialized behavior and that's
certainly something that we study in
forensics
let's don't forget cosby is a a serial
perpetrator this is something that has
kind of at least through the timelines
has been proven over and over and over
again the problem is this there's not a
lot of physical evidence tie back in
this case
but this behavior where he is utilizing
the quaaludes
is very very significant evidence
rapper tory lanez is being charged with
assault three months after
fellow rapper megan v stallion's public
allegations
the savage rapper megan vistallion
posted on instagram
that tory lanez had shot her in the foot
during an altercation this summer
tory lanez faces a felony assault charge
along with a felony charge for carrying
an unregistered firearm in a vehicle
tory lanez allegedly shot at megan's
feet when she exited his
suv in the hollywood hills if convicted
he faces a max sentence
of 22 years and eight months in prison
terry megan the the stallion sorry
recently performed at snl last week
speaking out about a number of issues
one of which was violence towards black
women
what was your reaction when you heard
that she was shot at multiple times and
struck in the heel
well you know brian i actually watched
her on saturday night live and she was
fantastic she had
two incredible performances but what
impressed me was the fact that she did
have these
powerful messages as a black woman i
really appreciated her
advocating for not just black women but
black men
as well so there's no doubt in my mind
that she was referring to what's going
on
in the world today cases like brianna
taylor and she wants to
make sure that people respect black
women and black women
right dina torrey lanes is looking at
two felony charges you add
on the immigration issues how do you see
this playing out for the canadian rapper
not that well to be honest i mean the
police were there that night they saw
the car
the gun in his car and if she now
cooperates they're gonna have
overwhelming evidence to be able to
convict him
i think though this is an interesting
example of just domestic violence in
general
and how women are often not even when
they're celebrities but
in public reluctant to cooperate and
speak
out and it you know it took her quite
some time rihanna with chris brown years
ago the same thing
it's a it's a comment not among just
celebrities but in general
exactly and to add on to that i think
it's going to be extremely difficult
because from my understanding
she posted on instagram some of the
images
of the shot to her heel subsequently
they were taken off of instagram but as
we all know once you put on the internet
it never really goes away so it seems
like the evidence is going to be
gathering there
dina dina dahl terry austin i want to
thank you both for joining us i want to
thank you of course
for joining us on the law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss
justice in america thank you have a good
day and we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
you